I just saw Freddy vs. Jason which you
guys know that movie it's yeah the
director is here that's way too
enthusiastic Freddy vs. Jason it's
Freddy from Nightmare on Elm Street
versus Jason Friday 13th it's actually
kind of Awesome but there's a part in it
where Freddy has to choose between
killing a white girl and killing a black
girl and Freddy says how sweet dark meat
yeah there's a collective groan from the
audience in the theater when I watched
it like people were disappointed in
Freddy Krueger fine with you murdering
children with your needle gloves but
racism
making it very hard to cheer for you
Freddy Krueger I hope Jason wins
mass-murdering monster but he's no bigot
you guys are wonderful I'll tell you a
personal story I'll tell you about the
first time I remember crying it's not
the funny part yet
Santa first I was five years old it's
not the first time I cried it's my first
memory of crying I was five I was
watching an animated version of an ugly
duckling yeah all these pretty ducklings
are so mean to this one ugly duckling
and who doesn't feel like an ugly
duckling when they were a kid you know I
remember just like bawling crying as
hard as I've ever cried tears down my
face I went to my mom for comfort and to
make me feel better my mom didn't say
you know beauty on the outside does not
matter canal its beauty on the inside
that makes a person she didn't say that
to make me feel better my mom said ducks
can't talk
these Ducks don't even exist look at it
someone just drew that stop cryin Kemal
they're not real she's a horrible way to
handle that situation my parents we
watched like the weirdest stuff that
they should not have let me watch like
when I was eight I swear they let me
rent the Elephant Man yeah I thought it
was a superhero movie you know like
Elephant Man he has the strength of 20
men no he doesn't he has the sadness of
20 man has not that movie the guy with
the face to get the girl to kiss when
you think I am NOT an animal devastating
that movie took something from me like
I'm sure I lost the ability to smell
rain during that movie I turned to my
mom and I was like Vanguard movies are
fake huh issues I actually know this one
is real
[Music]
the natural disease anybody could get
goodnight I just moved to Los Angeles a
few months ago and I had a I had a show
in Orange County okay you're not gonna
like this joke
I never been all I know is you know the
Housewives of Orange County so it has a
certain reputation I was kind of nervous
I was gonna go I get there I get out of
my car ten seconds after I get out of my
car ten seconds after I get out of my
car this car pulls up this guy pokes his
head out the window yells at me he's
like hey Kumar where's Harold like
you've been waiting on the corner for
weeks like I can't wait for a brown to
come to town I've got a pop-culture
reference that will be little to him and
I got so angry now it's trying to think
like why do I get so angry when
somebody's racist to me and it's cause
when somebody's racist to you there are
no comebacks there is nothing you can
say it when like what are you gonna do
be racist back to them no because you're
not racist and most of the people who
are racist to me are white and it's very
difficult to be racist to white people
like what am I gonna be like oh I'm
Kumar well you're the lead in most
movies that come out
I think about it for nice later like
three nights later I'll be in bed I
won't be able to sleep on like that guy
was so racist to me he called me Kumar
which is pretty close to my name that's
just a terrible coincidence that's the
only reason I want to be famous I want
to be so famous that I'm the pop-culture
reference that people would make to try
and be racist to me you know so I'll be
walking down the street and car will
pull up and be like hey look at this
Kumail Nanjiani oh no that is Kemal Nagi
[Music]
thank you for knowing my name
[Applause]